how to get hired on oDesk I'm a big
believer in oDesk
I love using Oh dance basically what it
is it's a website that connects
employers with employees remotely and
people can bid on projects and as an
employer you can go and find people to
work on whatever it is that you need
help with if it's programming or graphic
design or administrative tasks whatever
it is so I've used aa desktop to bring
on video editors marketing assistants
personal assistants graphic designers
data entry people tons of different jobs
increasing this world we don't have to
actually have somebody in our office to
do work for us so I'm a big believer in
that in the tool and I got recently
asked a question on YouTube by somebody
who wrote in to say I'm a web designer
graphic designer local designer how can
I get started and attract people to hire
me on oDesk fences from give like now
usually I'm at I'm answering questions
for entrepreneurs who might be on the
other side who are wondering about how
to hire people so it's cool to be asked
by the employee side and and I do have a
lot of great advice so here it is your
my tips if you are looking to get hired
on oDesk okay the first thing is have a
picture of you smiling okay most people
on oDesk they have a picture but if it's
not in your culture a lot of times
people have very serious pictures like
this and remember who you're selling to
okay the people who are going to pay you
the bigger dollars are the ones
typically in North American culture and
for us we like pictures of smiling
people so don't look like a serial
killer have a smiling picture of you
looking professional okay I can't tell
you how many pictures I've seen of
people who are very serious and they
might be in their undershirt or
something like nobody's gonna hire you
if that's what you're looking like they
don't care if you're attractive or not
what you look like
but look professional have a suit on and
smile just that already will help
separate you from most of the people who
are out there okay number two pass the
tests okay with oDesk you give
a chance to look for to apply for
different tasks so it could be English
speaking tasks it could be customer
service tests it could be data entry
tests it could be about programming a
specific language it tests you and as an
employer they'll often look at that if
I'm hiring a PHP programmer I want to
know that you passed and scored well on
the PHP programming test okay it's not
enough just to pass it you got to score
while I don't want somebody who can just
barely get by and so when you're taking
the test prepare for it study for it
don't don't have something else going on
in the background listening to youtube
videos or being distracted on chat take
it seriously because employers will take
those test scores seriously so take the
test and prepare for them number three
pay attention to the job application
whenever I put out a job I get hundreds
of people who are interested in it which
is great but most people never fully
read the job application now I make it a
little difficult on purpose because as
an employer I got killed trying to go
through all these applications so I'll
write one big ugly paragraph and in the
middle write something like how many
Twitter followers do I have and put that
in the first sentence of your job
application and 80% of people don't do
that 80% of people won't even read that
line and give me my answer so you think
I'm going to hire that person no read
the job application okay this may sound
like simple basic things that most
people are not doing it okay number four
find a way to make it personal find a
way to stand out okay the ones who I've
hired who made it an impression on me
are the ones who always left something
personal in the job application like I
went to your website and I really
enjoyed whatever article or I saw your
YouTube video and it really spoke to me
you don't wanna you don't wanna lie
about something you want to be honest
you want to make it personal but that
extra little touch immediately makes you
stand out over everybody else so do it
and in the last one my last point number
five is over-deliver okay because the
most popular people I find on oDesk they
already have jobs with somebody else
because those employers don't want to
let them go over deliver be responsive
the thing I hate the most and the thing
that worries people a lot is
communication if somebody writes to you
especially from different time zones you
want to make sure that you're responding
quickly and you're giving your employee
back to your employer more than what
they asked for
make them love to have you write they're
hiring you for their business you need
to become an important part of their
business you have to be so important
that if you leave there they're in a big
hole that's how not only you get hired
but how you can start increasing your
prices you have to be super important to
that business okay so those are my how
many five tips one have a picture to
answer the questions on the test and
prepare for it three read the Job
Description everything through four
personalize it and number five over
deliver like crazy for your employer
that's it you do that you'll be an O
test superstar believe those are
watching like a video give it a thumbs
up below if you have a question for me
or comment leave it below
I love seen those come in to thank you
so much and I'll see you soon